today we're going to look at the new  smugglers bounty subscription box from  Funko there's lots of exclusive items in  here it's all exclusive it is Star Wars  theme you can get this $25 every other  month go to smugglers bounty calm and  order yours so where you see what is  inside is bb-8 here okay one thing you  get every month is a patch so here we  have bb-8 resistance put that on there  is also a pen this one is Poe Dameron  every month you will get a t-shirt so  this one is the force awakens Funko  style there is also like a c-3po hop  ceramic mug you notice it's got the red  like he has in force awakens now these  mugs are not microwave safe they're not  dishwasher safe so they have to be  careful but it's a nice sturdy ceramic  mug and the last thing  is exclusive Chewbacca now there is a  Chewbacca available this one is a fuzzy  one so that's what makes it exclusive  can't get this anywhere else  you